welcome back this is the Ben Shapiro
show on a really dark day for the
country we're taking your calls at eight
five five two three six thirty two
twenty eight that's eight five five two
three six 32:28 Gabriel and Virginia are
on the bench pure shot go for it
Gabriela yes hi Ben I am asking as a
Hispanic I've had a big problem with the
term person of color and with close
family and friends asking me why I'm not
agreeing with our fully I guess on their
stance what is your answer when someone
says that people are acting this way
because of being enslaved you know years
and years ago
not a single riot or was it has lived
under slavery not a single one now there
have their parents not to have the
grandparents in either of the
great-grandparents almost their great
grandparents were SuperDuper old so that
that is that is a it is an astonishing
thing to claim that you are robbing a
footlocker because of slavery like that
just that it does not work that way now
if you want to say that there is poverty
that is the historical lingering effect
of slavery or Jim Crow you can make that
argument in terms of wealth I think that
it's an argument that has been wildly
overstated that the vast majority of day
to day poverty is still dependent on
individual decision making it in the
United States particularly 60 years
after these civil rights era but if you
are claiming that people are rioting and
looting because they're angry about
slavery then you're going to have to
explain why other groups that have been
oppressed in the United States and
abroad don't routinely go and riot and
loot and the answer is because this has
nothing to with slavery in fact it
doesn't even have anything to do with
police brutality this has to do with a
bunch of people who are taking advantage
of a of a really hot situation in order
to go get a TV and that's disgusting
and it's evil the name of anybody who
suggests that is justified because
America is deeply racist and endemically
racist see this is the biggest problem
that I have with the media and our
politicians and our political class is
that at the same time they are saying
the president Trump he's so inflammatory
so terrible they've spent decades
indoctrinating people into the belief
that America is deeply endemically
unchangeably racist and that it's people
are racists as well and so if you grow
up believing that if you grew up
believing that America was racist and
that all of its institutions are racist
then you'd be striking a blow for
liberty by going and robbing the footlok
or perhaps or at least you could
theoretically make that case and you see
this from people like Spike Lee you seen
this from Don Lemon you seen this from
Charles blow the idea is that rioters
looters are somehow justified because
after all they are fighting the
quote-unquote system and the system is
racist in general it's a vile argument
it's historically untrue I mean the fact
is that the United States has changed if
people have noticed just a little bit
since 1964 and a change in an awful lot
since 1865 and the this this notion that
rioting and looting are justified by by
anger against police officers again I'm
wondering who exactly is defending
police brutality at this point I'm
really not seeing a lot of defenses of
police brutality and beyond that I I
still have yet to see the non feelings
based anecdotal based evidence that
police officers all over the country are
unduly are unduly targeting black people
this idea that racist police officers
are dominant across the American
landscape is not supported by the
evidence it is not I mean the fact is
that when people cite instances they
like to say things like stop and frisk
the fact is I'd stop and frisk targeted
blacks and Hispanics at about rate of
eighty-five percent of all stops and
frisks in New York City where black and
Hispanic and over 90% of all street
crime in New York City as reported by
victims of street crime was black and
Hispanic does that mean that the police
officers are racist does that mean that
there is something wrong with the police
officers or are the police officers
responding to crime in this generalized
notion that police officers are
willy-nilly going out and shooting
unarmed black men it's not true
statistically speaking it is not true in
fact if you are a a white person who is
in a confrontation with police and some
sort of armed confrontation with police
you're more likely to be shot by the
police and if you are black
according to statistics put together by
Roland fryer the the situations in which
armed people are being shot very often
those situations are under conflict
because somebody is attacking and got an
officer with a gun is that person
unarmed or is that person not unarmed
like Michael Brown was shot while he was
unarmed does after he tried to take a
gun off a police officer and fired a
couple of shots into his car and then
attempted to charge him that's not being
shot while unarmed that that's not shot
unjustifiably okay so the the attempt to
to castigate all police officers across
the country is racist or more broadly
all Americans as racist than justify
rioting and looting the this I will say
the soft bigotry of low expectations
here is absolutely incredible it really
is the notion that you can't control
yourself enough to not to not rob a
target they need you really like your
anger in America made you break into
that ATM at
target is just insane everyone else is
expected to behave decently except for
rioters and looters as long as the issue
happens to be a racial issue according
to the media it's that it's incredible
it's incredible mm-hmm thank you so much
you bet it's a I mean if you've noticed
that I have some passion on this issue
it's because I really believe that the
downfall of the country comes in this
the downfall of the country comes down
to do you believe that America is
irredeemably irremediably racist that
America is evil and terrible all the way
through do you think that America is is
garbage and therefore deserving of being
torn down and that most Americans are
garbage and therefore deserving of
whatever happens to them if you believe
that then America has no future there
cannot be a vote there cannot be a
Republican conversation there cannot be
any sort of democratic procedure none of
that is going to alleviate the
fundamental evil of America and that's
what a lot of people on the Left are
pushing for and it's disgusting truly
disgusting all righty Jake in Florida
you're on the bench perish I'll go for
it Jake
hey Ben my question was something you
said earlier on earlier today was about
the liability threshold the immunity for
state government which I think in
Florida is low I think it's $200,000
which as far as liability goes that's
that's pretty low I was wondering that
seems like an issue that we can come
together on the left with the change and
I was wondering what you think some
other issues are that we can kind of
come together with and if maybe you were
had the idea to do maybe like a daily
wire policy section where you can
advocate these policies over political
divide you know it's it's a news it's a
news website and the and so we tend not
to put out you know actual policy
statements because we're not a political
campaign but I think there are some
issues where theoretically if the left
were honest they could agree so for
example there's the question of a
doctrine called qualified immunity it
shields police and government officials
from accountability for illegal and
unconstitutional acts the Supreme Court
created it in 1982 and it's largely
unlimited I mean it creates this broad
in
unity that is too broadly applied I
would say limiting qualified immunity
would make a lot of sense because again
if you act outside the scope of
authority I'm not sure exactly why you
should be granted immunity number one I
think that juries take into account the
fact that police officers have hard jobs
but I think the idea that police
departments can't be sued if if
something goes wrong or the idea that if
you are a police officer and you do
something deeply egregiously wrong that
the union has to protect you or
something like that doesn't that doesn't
seem to make a lot of sense to me I
think there are there areas where we can
come together on some of this stuff but
we can't come together so long as your
fundamental starting points is that this
isn't an issue of police procedure it's
an issue of American racism now if you
believe it's an issue of police
procedure then we can change the
procedures in order to deal with the
failure to handle the procedures right
we've done that in Los Angeles in Los
Angeles
there was baton training after Rodney
King there are all sorts of procedures
that were put in place to limit the
ability of police to do things without
supervision after the rampart scandal
here in LA you've seen this across the
country but if you don't actually
believe that this is a procedural
problem or even a problem of staffing if
you believe that no matter who you staff
in the police the police because they're
an institute of law enforcement and law
enforcement in America's historically
racist and therefore you can never have
a non racist law enforcement in the
United States almost presumably to stop
by black Americans and then even if it
is staffed by black Americans it's still
racist because it's internalized racism
which is what you see from a lot of
people well then there's no solution in
the offing and this is where you know I
mean asking for honest solutions from
the left honest solutions from the left
would be good they're not seeing a lot
of honest solutions from the left you
know why because it turns out that the
vast majority of these instances that we
are seeing are in democrat-controlled
cities and where they've been running
the PD la has been run by Democrats at
nearly my entire lifetime New York has
been run by Democrats for the last what
decade and a half since Rudy Giuliani
left office and Michael Bloomberg
switched parties majors hit Chicago has
never been run by a Republican
Minneapolis hasn't been run by a
Republican for 50 years so is this
really about policy or is this really
about a deeper argument which is that
America's law-enforcement bodies are
suspect and are racist and any aspect of
police brutality is non procedural
problem it's a racial problem this is
the big problem you can't agree with
people who have fundamentally different
starting points Charles in Minneapolis
Minnesota you're on the bench Peoria for
Charles oh hello yeah I just want to
you're a green person and I like it I
like watching you and this is really why
I'm coming out to ask you this question
so I'm here at the epochs and every
Center of the protests and the rights
that are growing on I've never
participated in any protests before and
I had other opportunities to protest but
I just never did I never saw the point
yesterday I live two blocks from the US
Bank Stadium where like over five K
people protest my fiance and I joined
that very peaceful everybody was helping
each other out giving out waters there
was children there and I know like why
would people bring children to a protest
but the fact of the matter is they did
but now there's been confirmed cases
that there aren't evil people who are
infiltrating these protests and these
found accelerates around the
neighborhood as Minneapolis my goal is
and that's why I'm asking you I am for
the people I don't want nobody likes to
be in danger I'm not looking for
information I just want to see what your
thought is of me going around just to
keep making sure I'm ah you know getting
a group together to like kind of secure
everybody that's doing this protest
peacefully and so that's my question I
mean so a couple of things one I think
that protesting is First Amendment
protected activity and if you feel the
necessity to protest go and do it I
would suggest that one of the things
that you do and what would be really
useful is some of these tapes that we're
seeing of people actually going and
talking to the police officers I go up
to police officers and instead of you
know what we see in some of these
protests yelling and chanting and all
this at the police officers recognize
that the police officers are generally
on your side and I think that would be a
very good thing you know extending the
conversation with the police is what's
going to actually help us come out of
the sort of thing so I think that's
useful I guess one of my questions is
when it comes to protest and what are
you protesting for well what do you
think is the what outcome are you
looking for here other than just
expressing that we all think police
brutality is bad which we do and I don't
think that we need to actually go out in
the streets to express that it's a bad
thing to kneel on a guy's neck for nine
minutes while he says you can't breathe
it seems like that's fairly obvious to
everybody so what political changes did
you be looking for my political change
is just the way that we implement the
police force and they're just responsive
time and just like the way that you know
they approach the situation instead of
just you know if things start to get out
of hand and police officer is
you know about to lose their cool you
know confining their partner because
they always have a partner with them or
D call for backup just you know that's
what I'm looking for the motor reason
why I went out to go walk in that
protestors today is because my
completion died from this that could
have been easily avoided like I was I'd
been a security officer before for like
ten years and the number one rule I knew
not to do was to put my knee on
somebody's neck or their Airways and
that's what I want well I mean again I
think that any call for it for changing
procedures or for the other three cops
who stood around in - nothing here - to
face charges for complicity in that I'm
again agreeing with that so you know if
you want a protest again I think that
you should I think that you should you
should go and you should talk with the
police officers I think that you know
you should you should obviously not I
think agree with the people who are
claiming that America is broadly
speaking racist and terrible because I
don't think that's true or that the
police are out to get black Americans I
don't think that's true either but I
think that distinguishing yourself and
going up to the media and distinguishing
yourself and saying listen those of us
here who are protesting have nothing to
do with these rioters and looters I
think that that's a I think that's a
very good thing that you're doing
actually thank you I appreciate you
think that well I appreciate it Charles
thanks so much for listening to the show
we're gonna take more of your calls
momentarily at eight five five two three
six thirty two twenty eight that's eight
five five two three six thirty two
twenty eight